la commanderie revient avec son eee noël
décalé une programmation 100% en ligne
cette année avec marché de noël virtuel
lectures musicales ou encore ateliers le
public nous manque que les artistes où
manquent les intervenants nous manque et
du coup on avait envie de ne pas rester
deux mois sans rien proposer à la
commanderie et de faire ce lien jusqu'à
la fin de l'année en espérant des jours
meilleurs mois de janvier les ateliers
sont accessibles à tous et variées au
programme fabrication de lanternes de
produits cosmétiques et réalisation de
recettes de cuisine et de cartes de noël
ou encore au yoga du rire
[Rires]
les ateliers pour les enfants des études
pour les adultes parce qu'on a envie lui
envie de concerner tous les publics
et donc voilà il suffit de s'inscrire de
choisir un ou des ateliers pour certains
ateliers le public vient chercher des
kits puisqu'on leur a préparé tout le
matériel pour pouvoir réaliser leur
fabrication en même temps que
l'intervenant en direct dit connexion au
maximum sont possibles par atelier une
fois inscrit un mémo est envoyé aux
participants indiquant leur ait un lien
pour se connecter
on se retrouve ensemble en visio comme
on a appris à le faire depuis quelques
mois des tous en visio voilà on a tout
organisé pour pour pouvoir les
accueillir
virtuellement à la commanderie d'autres
ateliers auront lieu ce week end
fabrication de mangeoires à oiseaux ou
encore emballage cadeau il encore
possible de s'y inscrire programme et
réservations sur le site de la
commanderie